depuis plus d'un an débit attend de
recevoir l'appel qui changera sa vie
comme quelques 5000 personnes à hamilton
elle est sur une liste d'attenté pour
obtenir un logement subventionné
son cas est pourtant prioritaire deby a
deux enfants et sort d'une relation
violente sans l'aide d'un organisme qui
vient en aide aux femmes vulnérables
elle serait à la rue car les loyers
hamilton sont hors de prix 4'
débit n'est pas la seule à ressentir les
contrecoups de la crise du logement
hamilton autrefois une agglomération
industrielle en banlieue lointaine de
toronto est devenu une des villes
canadiennes où le prix des propriétés
augmente le plus vite presque 30% dans
la dernière année
est agent immobilier d'un exemple d'un
condo dont il n'a pas réussi à conclure
l'achat même en offrant 10 % de plus à
ses propriétaires
pour ce chercheur a mérité mais une
victime collatérale de la frénésie
immobilière torontoise
dans ceux de l'ontario tout le monde
connaît quelqu'un qui connaît quelqu'un
qui a déménagée à hamilton dit il
souvent il s'agit de familles qui
seraient incapables de s'offrir une
maison à toronto mais si elle n'était
n'a jusqu'à présent été une option plus
abordable la crise du logement a changé
la donne brian douce et y voit
d'ailleurs un phénomène pancanadien
au milieu d'une campagne électorale
serrée où les circonscriptions du grand
toronto rgt risque d'être déterminante
le logement s'est rapidement imposé
comme un enjeu incontournable
les chèvres connaissent l'existence
d'une crise et multiplie les promesses
mais
les libéraux s'engagent à construire ou
rénover 1 million 400 mille logements
les conservateurs vont construire un
million et les néo-démocrates 500 milles
ce sont des logements à louer mais c'est
au prix du marché mais l'un des sens
avec la région d'hamilton et mettent en
oeuvre des projets de logement abordable
si elle se réjouit de voir que les chefs
s'intéresse à la crise du logement elle
reste sceptique devant leur promesse de
construire plus de maison parce qu'avoir
un million de nouvelles maisons à vendre
dans les prochaines années ça va être
assez est-ce que ça est-ce que ça va
vraiment résoudre le problème on peut
augmenter l'offre mais la demande est
toujours là débit non plus ne font pas
beaucoup d'espoir sur le prochain
gouvernement à ottawa
si les politiciens était dans mes
souliers il comprendrait peut-être
l'urgence de la situation
lance-t-elle
peu intéressés par la campagne
électorale elle continue d'attendre la
pelle qui lui permettra de tourner la
page sur une période difficile de sa vie
un nouveau départ qui tombera à point
ici à ce midi radio canada à merten